near automata is an absolute Masterpiece
having never played the near series
until just recently I'd spent the past s
years only hearing about other people's
experiences with the game and now that
I've reached the end I can say with
absolute certainty that everything
anyone has ever said about the game is
true from the themes of its narrative to
the story structure to even how it
Blends its gameplay systems into the
story near automata is an impressive
production from start to finish and
today I'd like to spend some time
talking about it in this video I'll not
only be retelling the story of near
utata so you understand what was going
on but I'll also be critiquing it along
the way sharing my thoughts on whether
or not a specific part of the story was
handled well in my eyes we'll also be
going into quite a few philosophical
discussions about various topics due to
the game subject matter as always feel
free to check out any of my other videos
which are similar in style to this video
but on a variety of games and series
like the video if you enjoy and
subscribe if you're new for more content
like this and as always let's get
started near automata's intro starts
incredibly fast not even wasting a
minute of time before immediately
throwing the player into the the thick
of it the first mission is light on the
story but we're only just getting
started from what we are given we are
part of a large group of soldiers
dedicated to killing the enemy right in
front of us based on the designs of each
group it seems like we play as the
humans while our enemies are robots and
machines which means that the game is
setting up a typical robots take over
the world kind of plot but that going to
be further from the truth and I'll
Circle back to that later the main
character of this game and the one we'll
be playing as throughout most of its
runtime needs no introduction but in
case you do need it this is your hot
type B number two better known as 2B
alongside 2B is another person named 9s
who together are going to take down the
Goliath class machine that's located at
this facility with the intro of autom
mod does well is plant seeds into the
player's mind as to how the people
within the game interact with the world
tub comes off as very professional and
by the books kind of character refusing
to waste time on idle chatter unless it
has something to do with the mission
whereas 9s is the complete opposite
spending precious Mission time talking
about himself and his fascination with
the machines that they're killing
eventually after some gameplay
encounters they come across the hulking
beasts that they're meant to take down
due to a sheer size the duo has to get
creative hacking its lopped off arm so
they could use it as a weapon as well as
employing the assistance of their flight
units 9s is injured in the fight which
prompts Tob to find him only for the
player to discover that 9s is not human
but rather a robot in fact 2B herself is
also a robot as read after this the duo
is cornered by more Goliath class
machines leaving them no other option
but to detonate the black boxes located
in their body this creates a miniature
siiz nuke destroying the Goliath along
with them in the blast fortunately the
next mission will pick up right after
this with both of them at their Base
called the bunker seemingly not injured
in the blast that's because they backed
up their memories stored in the current
body so they could access them later
when they went to another body except 9s
didn't have enough time to back up his
so while tb's memories remained the last
memory of 9s is when we first meet him
at the beginning of the level all things
considered Near opata starts off quite
well from a gameplay perspective at
least as they said the story is quite
light here in the opening moments and
for good reason but the gameplay was
able to keep me entertained all
throughout one aspect of it that I did
find quite interesting was how the game
never forgets that it is a the game
Neato often switches camera angles
During certain parts of the level and
they behave like those Styles would in
any other game whether that's a top-
down perspective or a 2d Sid scroller it
keeps things fresh and just like how a
horror game might be linear so the team
can craft the exact scenario they want
the player to uncover changing these
camera angles lets the team apply the
same method of game design either by
hiding how many enemies are actually in
the arena or just using it to Simply add
a bit of flavor to an encounter it even
manages to blend the game and Story by
using the menus as a mechanic 2B is a
robot so since all of her systems are
mechanical the game decided to put all
the HUD elements in the skills menu so
to turn off the health bar damage
numbers and mini map you have to
physically remove the chip from your
skills menu the game even has a comedic
ending tied to this as well as removing
your OS chip causes Tob to die and you
get a game over likewise saving the game
is a kind of backing up your memories in
game as like we saw with 9s you only
keep the memories you backed up so dying
and going back to the previous save is
like returning to when you last backed
up tub's memory it's genuinely
impressive how tied together the
gameplay and story are becoming and it's
only going to get more mixed as we
continue
that said the biggest question the
player will likely have is what the hell
is going on humans that aren't human but
robots weird lifelike machines attacking
other robots what exactly is the plot of
this game well I'll gladly explain but
that's going to require a bit of a
history lesson into not just near
automata but Yoko taro's other works see
otata is just one game in a two game
series called near but before making
near he also made another series called
dracken guard and ended up using that
series as a jumping off point for near
however pretty much every connection
made here is extremely loose to explain
further Dragon guard 1 is where the
connection starts which stars the
protagonist Kim and his Dragon Angelus
at the end of the game these two end up
fighting the major antagonist of the
story The Queen Beast depending on
certain choices made throughout the game
though you'll be given a different
ending in this case we want to focus on
ending e where all three of them are
thrown into a portal into modern-day
Japan I should clarify that draing guard
takes place in a typical fantasy setting
so going through this portal is about as
bizarre as it sounds defeating her
grants you the final cut scene which
sees Kim and Angelus shot down by a
Japanese fighter jet originally this was
conceived of as a joke ending something
that's not Cannon but funny enough to
laugh at but apparently Yoko Taro found
it compelling enough to use as the start
of his next story as this modern-day
setting is the world of near like I said
loose connection so loose in fact that
you really don't even have to play
Dragon guard to understand near there is
nothing wrong with playing the games if
you want to but if you're more
interested in the near series then you
don't need to worry about playing these
other entries I didn't and I think I
came out okay but don't worry if you
want to hear more about dragonard then I
got you covered as fan of the channel
and allaround great guy your favorite
son made a video on the dragen guard and
near series he was also kind enough to
let me use his dragen guard footage
which you've been seeing throughout this
video so if you're curious about someone
else's opinions on near or just
interested in seeing what dragen guard
is all about then I highly recommend his
video on the series I'll leave it link
Down Below in the description if you
happen to stop by his channel tell my CA
regardless this ending takes us to near
which as if the idea of an alternate
universe wasn't already enough of a
headache near attempts to make our
symptoms chronic by coming with its own
set of baggage that's because NE has two
different versions the Japanese version
called near replicant and the North
American version called near Gestalt
which was just shorten to near on the
box the biggest difference between the
two is the protagonist and the
relationship to Yona one of the game's
main characters while both are called
near then gestal it's a father whose
daughter is Yona and in replicant it's a
brother whose sister is Yona apparently
this was due to a difference in culture
and the team felt that a fatherdaughter
relationship was more appealing to w
Wern audiences now while they would like
to get up here and say how offensive it
is for them to stereotype us Americans
like that both parts of The Last of Us
won multiple Awards and even game of the
year so touche for the sake of the video
though we're only going to be talking
about the replicant version as it's also
the only one to receive a remaster which
I assume most newcomers likely played so
I'll be using that one to reference
throughout the video near however starts
with a widespread plague that's because
the magic Essence and particles that
Angelus and the Queen Beast carried over
started infecting the world this viral
outbreak was was then called the white
chlorination syndrome and after a few
decades most of humanity was already
wiped out to combat this threat project
Gestalt was created which be able to
sidestep the virus by removing the body
from the soul letting the two live on a
separate entities unfortunately talking
any further about this would spoil the
plot of near aomata but let's just say
that after a few thousand years the
white chlorination syndrome was a thing
in the past and people were able to move
on this then brings us to near utata for
the sake of establishing a timeline Dron
guard's ending e happened in 2003 near
replicant starts in the year 3465 and
your automata begins in
11,945 ad over 8,000 years later I'm
starting to sound like a broken record
here but like I said loose connections
they are everywhere in this series to
dial it back a bit 512 ad is when near
automata starts to become relevant as
during this time and I can't believe I'm
saying this but literal aliens invaded
Earth both the humans and the aliens
brought back up in the form of robotic
life forms the human used Androids and
the aliens used machines to clarify a
bit the human looking robots like 2B 9s
and all the others who meet throughout
the game are the Androids and the robot
looking robots the ones will be mainly
killing throughout the game are the
machines the aliens were quite effective
in their takeover as they were able to
destroy 80% of the world in a very short
amount of time this caused the rest of
humanity to fly to the moon while the
Androids stayed here to finish the fight
which is where we come in as an Android
employed by yorha we have one objective
kill every machine you see and bring an
end to this war once and for all
so to summarize we have gone from a
fantasy world in an alternate Dimension
to modern-day Tokyo which ends up
leading to a worldwide disease that
kills almost every human in the world to
then having aliens invade Earth
resulting in US attempting to stop them
from taking over the world what an
absolute show of a timeline this
has become there are a lot more details
involved in this timeline but we'll have
to Circle back to them later though as
these certain elements are tied to the
game story but hopefully I painted a
good enough picture for you to get
caught up returning to where we left off
2B and 9s just blew themselves up trying
to destroy one of the Goliath class
machines that was on Earth even though
both of them are fresh out of storage
and just woke up a job's a job so they
need to talk with command to figure out
their next assignment this time they are
to go down to the surface and meet with
some of the resistance members it's
important to mention once again that
none of the people we interact with in
the entire game are human all of them
are on the moon so these human- looking
robots from the resistance are just like
2B and 9s Androids since it's still
pretty early in the game and we just got
thrown into a new area all these
missions are extremely basic and there
to teach the player the fundamentals
from everything to combat and
exploration to how to upgrade and shop
for new gear but while this is happening
the missions are also attempting to Clue
the player in into what's going on
showing them that not everything is as
it seems throughout these fights you'll
notice that the machines are speaking
back to you something that they
shouldn't be capable of because they're
just machines and once we make it to the
desert region we'll find a large
Congregation of them all attempting to
replicate the wonderful Act of sexual
intercourse for complete beginners
they're pulling off some expert level
moves I've never seen before so clearly
I should be taking notes but but
eventually the machines start to go wild
and form into a massive hive mind giving
birth to someone named Adam despite
looking human he like everything else is
just a machine Adam is the first machine
to not look like a typical machine to
make matters worse killing him causes
his brother Eve to appear out of his
chest see for his primitive and goofy as
these machines seem they're actually
surprisingly complex and is likely why
the war has gone on this long I don't
recall the game explaining how this is
possible but for some reason the
machines can evolve by eating the
corpses of their victims and
assimilating them the machines also have
their own server called The Machine
Network and just like the Androids they
can keep coming back to life as long as
their Central core isn't destroyed as
for Adam and Eve well their names are
about as subtle as an explosion as
they're clearly meant to mimic Adam and
Eve from the Bible I'm not particularly
well versed in the Old Testament but
from my understanding Adam and Eve were
the first humans ever created in the
context of near aomata assuming that
Adam and Eve are a new kind of machine
the next evolutionary step so to speak
is are the only machines that are
created to look like this for whatever
reason despite seeing this both 2B and
9s decide to just send the data over to
command and move on luckily for them
they have another assignment to take
their mind off things which is to find a
few Androids that went missing not too
long ago this mission is about as
bizarre as the previous one as the
locator takes them to an amus Park
filled with machines all dressed in
carnival attire reveling in the
festivities none of them attack you
however in fact many of them are quite
friendly and even let you peruse their
Wares the main boss of this location is
also the one who took the Androids a
giant machine ballerina which fits more
in line with the rest of the machines
we've been faced with killing her and
leaving the theater though sees the two
being called over by another friendly
machine who then takes them to a village
filled with other machines according to
their leader not only do they not have
beef with any Androids but they don't
even want to fight at all so in the
middle of this entire war is a small
village of pacifist machines while the
central plot of near utata is about the
war between the Androids and machines
it's really just used as an excuse to
move the story from one location to the
next as the real plot is much deeper
than that it's a story about questioning
your own existence determining what
qualities make up humanity and whether
or not those can to be applied to
anything even if they don't look human
and most importantly finding purpose in
a purposeless world we could look at
some of the game side quest to
understand this a bit more like any
other open world game near AATA has a
ton of optional missions for the player
to do and just about every one of them
is important as one way or another they
all connect to the main theme of the
game some of the first side quest you'll
receive will be from the resistance or
other yoran members one of which has you
investigating a recent disappearance
only to find out that a machine was
angry that its friends were killed so it
lured a bunch of other resistance
members to its Hideout and killed them
another member of the resistance is
interested in in Cuisines so we need to
gather some meat from the surrounding
Wildlife so he could prepare a dish that
he wanted to make as for the yorha
soldiers one of our missions has us
helping out operator 6o by photographing
a pretty flower called the desert rose
and another wants you to look into a
friend who disappeared and hasn't been
heard from in a while only to find out
that she died and actually plan on
deserting from yorha if she managed to
survive the battle these are pretty
run-of-the-mill missions and something
you might expect from this game but just
roll with me here for a second see it's
not just Androids who give you missions
as some machines will also ask you for
assistance too their first Quest usually
come from the village of machines run by
their leader Pascal one of which is
about a girl machine whose sister ran
off to the desert and hasn't come back
for a few days so she wants us to go
find her and bring her back the mission
is pretty straightforward find the
sister defend her from the other
machines and mission complete another
has us coming across their mother and
child arguing to which the child machine
decides to leave the village and live on
his own as you would expect that doesn't
go well as we have to defend the kid
from a few machines we also telling him
that he should make up with his mother
when he returns eventually after making
it back to the Village safe and sound
the two have a heart to- heart make up
and promise to communicate better in the
future from an outside perspective from
someone who hasn't played this game
before I could see how highlighting
these specific quests would be confusing
or even pointless and that's completely
true a quest about a parent and child
arguing which eventually leads to you
chasing after that child is extremely
boring and fits in line with the type of
quest you might get in the tutorial area
of an MMO but when framed in the way
that nomata puts it that it's not humans
but machines doing human like things
then these start to have more weight
remember every single person we come
across in this game is either an Android
or or a machine yet why is it that the
former missions feel runof-the-mill
while the lads isn't I think it has to
do with how our subconscious mind works
a funny moment I had while playing the
game was the time I realized that all
the resistance members were Androids I
remember the game saying that all the
humans were on the moon which is why I
was confused why humans were still on
the surface later I figured out that
these were just Androids and I felt like
that only happened because I
subconsciously attributed their
behaviors to that of humans because they
look like one realistically both the
Androids and Machines are made up of
mechanical Parts due to their appearance
but I feel like most people people
aren't alarmed by the human-like
qualities of an Android as opposed to
that of a machine because they look
human so the mind just accepts it as
normal both groups have a quest where we
have to find a missing person and yet
for the Androids it's normal but for the
machines it's weird interestingly 2B and
9s will occasionally comment on the
missions they embark on and more often
than not it's about the machines and how
weird it is that they have similar
properties to humans yet rather than
mentioning how similar they are to
Androids they Instead try to justify it
in some way either by attributing it to
something else or just flat out denying
the possibility are you saying this
thing wanted Revenge oh come on now that
concept is far too complex for a machine
she sure cares about her little sister
huh still it's pretty funny to hear
machines talk about siblings do you
think she just means they were built at
the same Factory or something maybe as I
said part of me believes that it's due
to how our brains work and how we
attribute these actions and Concepts as
human so when we see something that
looks human our brain just assumes it's
normal but when it's something not human
it seen as strange I don't know if I was
the only person to go through this but I
did find it a bit odd in retrospect how
was when to accept that the Androids
having emotions is normal while machines
having them is not when realistically
they're all Cut From the Same Cloth it's
why I also said that the side quests
always have some kind of meaning as each
one of them ends up making you question
what Being Human truly means in addition
to this we also have to remember that
these missions have you defending
machines from other machines pascow
mentions at one point that the machines
that live in the village are
disconnected from the network according
to him this is because the aliens
stopped checking in about a couple
hundred years ago and they also felt
that to be free and peaceful they needed
to be alone with their minds since the
machine network is kind of like a
collective intelligence so as a result
the machine seem to mindlessly attack
anything that's not a part of the
network breaking off from the machine
network is like the machine equivalent
of developing free will now the machines
can think for themselves they start
asking questions about their existence
and start assigning roles and creating
bonds with other people all of which are
simply based on their own thoughts
nothing in the machine biology
determines which machine is which gender
or which one is older Pascal for
instance is male but has a more feminine
sounding voice as he believes it helps
Soo the minds of the children it starts
to blur the lines between machines
Androids and humans regarding where one
ends and the other begins if we're
talking physically then you could make
the argument that an organic body is
part of Being Human but those more
pedantic than I could mention how all
mammals are organic so the next best
thing would be the concept of Free Will
since we as humans can think and act as
well as develop emotions but as we've
seen both the Androids and machines have
already been able to do this this idea
about machines having humanlike
qualities is also what makes near aomata
just a fantastic piece of art to me many
stories about robots being more lifelike
also have the same Concepts like
understanding emotion and being able to
love others unconditionally and while
near AATA also does this it goes much
further with this comparison tub's
operator 6 calls her for a regularly
scheduled contact except you could hear
over the phone that she is crying
according to her she asked out one of
the operators but was rejected and now
she's upset going as far as to say that
she doesn't want to live anymore due to
the Heartbreak this is something
everyone's likely gone through where
your crush isn't into you and you think
it's the end of the world that you
rather perish than continue living
obviously no one is actually serious
about this but it's a very human like
trait to use extreme language in
situations that aren't super important
in the grand scheme of things there's
also this one string of missions
regarding a machine who ended up
creating a farm for injured animals as
like humans he developed an affection
for them was last mission has us go and
take out the group of rabbit animals as
they've been causing trouble for his
animals when we arrived we discovered
that the leader of the pack is a machine
dressed as a moose well extremely funny
it's also quite fascinating this idea of
the machine being the pack leader is
kind of like the old folk tale where the
kid was raised by the Wolves as
according to its backstory the young
machine was able to find sess in peace
amongst the pack but after defeating the
group and returning to the machine we
tell him that we took care of the
problem and that his animals are safe
but the leader was another machine who
unfortunately had to be put down to my
surprise however the machine didn't care
at all about this detail only looking
for reassurance that his animals were
okay as that's all that mattered to him
he like humans cared for his animals and
also grew an attachment to them the
longer he cared for them that's what
makes this game so impressive it's not
only showing how our emotions were
transferred over to the machines but
also our mannerisms and quirks things
that are deep in our subconscious mind
are reflected in these machines and is
why near aomata has one of the better
stories regarding robot and human
emotion because it tries to blow the
lines as much as possible going beyond
the basic fundamentals of emotion and
feeling but instead going deeper into
how we act it's why attached to most
comments and videos about this game are
words existential crisis because this
game really makes existence seem pretty
confusing fortunately we don't have to
do all that thinking alone this
discussion has naturally started swaying
into the Realms of philosophy and for
good reason near timana is filled with
philosophical Concepts and reference
many of which are tied to the quest we
just discussed and having this open
dialogue with the game really gets you
thinking about our life and our purpose
in this world the best place to start
would be with one of the more blatant
examples of philosophy in this game and
that's this machine named Jean Paul when
first meeting with the man he goes on
this long spiel about existence and how
man is nothing more than what he makes
of himself you'll then eventually meet
some of his followers all of whom want
to bring him gifts however upon
receiving them he tosses them aside
saying that they are not only worthless
trash but when asked if we should report
back to his followers he says it's not
worth the time he's a pretty peculiar
character but Jean Paul happens to be
based on the real life philosopher Jean
Paul satra who is most well known for
being a figurehead for existentialism
and having an open relationship with his
partner at the time I promise that Last
Detail will be important later like his
machine counterpart Jean Paul preached
about human existence and what purpose
and value humans have his most famous
quote is existence precedes essence
which claims that humans are not born
with value but rather create their own
further saying that as humans we can
decide and determine what we do with our
life freely and without constraint and
that our existence grants us the essence
that we choose this was originally used
as a Counterpoint for the original quote
Essence precedes existence which is the
opposite that humans are born with value
and purpose rather than finding said
purpose on their own unfortunately the
quest itself does not delve as much into
Jean Paul as we have but the ideas that
the real Jean Paul talks about can be
used to discuss other parts of the game
if humans have the opportunity to claim
Essence through actions is that what
separates us from Androids and machines
the machines and Androids were created
by the creators the aliens and humans to
fight against each other the Creator
were given in essence or purpose before
existence while the creators existed
before their Essence another example
would be on the other side of the
conflict with the Androids as the
shopkeeper wants us to get some specific
materials for his leg in actuality he
just needs some extra supplies this has
nothing to do with his leg because he
doesn't plan on repairing it since he's
an Android everything about him is
mechanical and over the years he's
replaced every part of his body except
this leg because to him it's the last
part of his original body and thus his
original identity this mission is based
on the thought experiment called the
ship of Theus which as asks if a ship is
the same ship even if all the parts have
been replaced with other pieces if all
the sails boards and nails were
different than the ones from the
original design is this still the same
that you started with if so then
you have your answer if not then where
is the line drawn between old and new
Thomas Hobbs another philosopher also
tried to extend this experiment asking
what it would mean if someone then took
those old parts of the ship and then
rebuilt them into a brand new ship it's
like taking all the pieces of a car
apart and then building it together from
scratch again is that still the same car
it's got all the pieces but but it was
taken apart and made into something else
so maybe not to some people the
untouched product right off the lot is
the original and anything afterward
whether that means replacing all the
parts or even deconstructing it only to
rebuild it once again would be changing
it into something new to others it's
something outside the parts like the
owner or the identity that changes its
distinction like all philosophical
experiments there is no right answer
it's only what you personally believe in
and to this man replacing that leg would
change his identity while on the topic
of identity we can also look at another
question that's called the teletransport
ation Paradox according to the
experiment if a person were to enter a
machine that copies their entire body
down to the molecules and then add
another machine on Mars output that
exact same copy with perfect Precision
are you no longer the same person or do
you stay the same thankfully we don't
have to look too far to see the
similarities to near AATA as if you
recall from the first mission both 2B
and 9s blew themselves up only to wake
up at the bunker their bodies weren't
recovered and repaired rather their
memories were put into another 2B and 9s
model I should also clarify that
multiple models do exist throughout the
game not just because of this but later
at the end of the game 9s is cornered by
a dozen 2B units none of whom are the 2B
we know back to the question is this the
same 2B in 9s despite being in different
bodies or is this change all that
matters when talking about identity if I
were to throw my two cents into all this
I find that my thoughts are quite
consistent replacing the body with
another doesn't change who you are and
changing all the parts of the ship
doesn't make it a different ship it's a
lot more complex than these thought
experiments tend to make it at least to
me anyway when I think of the ship I'd
probably draw the line of the whole ship
itself not the ship parts but rather the
ship as a whole buying a new ship
entirely would make it different cuz not
so much the physical parts but rather
the experiences themselves are the most
important you might have changed every
part of that ship but the experiences
you had with it over the years make it
the same one the stuff with 2B though is
a little bit trickier as it is the same
body type but not the original body and
because they're mechanical it's also not
technically the same mind either but
rather they're older memories being put
into a different machine similar to how
you would transfer a flash drive of data
from one computer to another it's
admittedly a bit hard to answer that
question and was also not the kind of
discussion I thought I'd be having when
finishing this game but here we are
still near a to modest ties to
philosophy and philosophical questions
go deep which is a different approach
than many other stories tend to take
while I don't know much about philosophy
as a whole I am familiar with it and
I've always been fascinated by the
thought experiments that come from these
Concepts it adds yet another layer of
complexity to the story allowing you to
analyze it from a purely narrative
perspective while also letting you go
deeper with its themes as you attempt to
connect them back to the main game
having finished both near games now I'm
starting to believe that Yoko Taro has a
fascination with humanity and how we as
a species operate as each game creates
discussions about how we live our
motivations for our actions and what our
purpose as humans
are apparently he's not the only one
who's fascinated by humans though as our
evil Duo Adam and Eve also want to know
what makes us tick to get to them 2B and
9s will eventually get a call from the
bunker saying that another Goliath class
machine is tearing apart the city
fighting one causes the ground to
crumble revealing a secret underground
tunnel and laboratory as well as a
notification that the aliens who haven't
shown their face in hundreds of years
have been underground the whole time
this causes the two to investigate right
away before realizing that all the
aliens are dead Adam and Eve ared
shortly after and corroborate the story
as not only did the aliens all die but
they also died out years ago and their
killers were the machines according to
Adam they rebelled against their
creators because they saw them as
infantile something weak and
simple-minded as I mentioned before
machines can evolve by devouring the
corpses of the beings they kill and
after 6,000 years of fighting they
eventually became more powerful than
their creator and no longer saw any
evolutionary advantage to being allied
with them but this is why they're so
interested in humanity as we are
extremely complex far beyond their
understanding and they want to well
understand us I should note that while
Adam is the one relaying this
information to us he is not the killer
of the aliens he's a part of the machine
Network which as we know allows them to
communicate and share knowledge so he's
really speaking on behalf of the
machines a large reason why he
specifically finds humans compelling is
something I've always known but never
thought about until he put it into words
as he says quote but the humans on the
moon now they're interesting they killed
uncountable numbers of their own kind
and yet loved in equal measure it's such
a small but extremely thought-provoking
comment because like the previous
discussions we've had a lot of this is
in our subconscious it comes stock once
you buy the human package Humanity since
the dawn of time has always fought
against each other and to Adam that's
something he doesn't understand out of
all the groups in this war the aliens
Androids machines and humans humanity is
the only one to succumb to infighting
Androids and machines were given the
goal of defeating the other side so the
they're all lined in that regard and the
aliens while not explicitly mentioned
are presumed to be the same as the
machines would not have wiped them out
otherwise humans are the only ones that
both fight for and against each other at
all times even though the machines do
fight each other on occasion this is
mainly because they left the network and
started thinking for themselves or to
put it another way they started thinking
less like machines and more like humans
it's what leads Adam to believe that the
core of humanity is conflict it's
Humanity in its purest form and in a way
he's kind of right every everything we
do usually involves conflict we protect
the ones we love attack the ones we
don't expand our territories and build
our Nations through conflict to go back
to our discussion about what makes
humans human and what separates them
from the Androids and machines who
attempt to replicate their ways of
living but one of the answers would be
interest specific conflict like I said
I'm pretty sure everyone knows this but
when I heard it from Adam I was a bit
taken aback because from an outside
perspective I can see how that seems
weird it's just that thanks to centuries
of human history repeating itself war
and conflict have always been one of our
defining features and it's something
that will likely not go away until we do
the machine's fascination with humans is
why they've also took to imitating them
something we've already seen throughout
the side quest what better way to
understand someone than doing exactly
what they do so they laugh cry celebrate
and procreate on an attempt to
understand us this leads to a rather
interesting discussion regarding this
phenomena however as machines have
evolved in many major ways over the past
6,000 years so much so that they could
be on these same level as humans in
terms of intelligence or at the very
least are close to it so who's to say
that it's not human nature to question
the world but the result of a heighten
intellect in the real world we are
easily the apex predators of the world
the most dominant species to ever exist
this is why we are the only ones capable
of complex thoughts these questions we
have about the universe life after death
and everything else came because we're
smart enough to start asking those
questions no other animal has done this
yet simply because they haven't reached
our level yet so maybe the machines
aren't imitating humans but rather when
a species eventually reaches a certain
level of intelligence they start to
behave the same way asking the same
questions about the world and what their
purpose is within it the only reason we
attribute this as something unique to
humanity is because no other species has
achieved this yet alternatively a major
question the player and likely the
machines had is what's the point of all
this then if their creators are dead
what's the point of fighting anymore
they also killed their creators too so
it's not like they just lost they
intentionally threw in the towel so
what's the point of Waring with the
Androids anymore well that's what many
of the machines we meet already thought
Pascal and his village as well as the
many other neutral machines all saw this
war as pointless and their leaders were
gone so they all disconnected from the
network and pave their own path thanks
to this though they've now become beings
without purpose their essence or their
reason for existing is gone so that they
have to find purpose in a world without
one on the other hand it could simply be
that because humanity is the most
diverse complicated and well-renowned
species the machines beings whose whole
goal is to evolve would naturally
gravitate towards the most evolved
species and that imitating us has
nothing to do with their intelligence
but is simply a byproduct of them trying
to understand us Strangely I think it's
all of it at once all of us me you
watching this video video and everyone
else in the world all has a purpose in
this world what that purpose is though
is entirely based on you it's why some
people may say that they were born for
this born to entertain and born to draw
that this is their purpose in life
everyone's purpose is different which is
why I've always been at the mindset that
the meaning of life is what you choose
to do with it life has no predetermined
meaning it's what you believe life is
worth living for each of these machines
has a different purpose in life those
within the network have the goal of
destroying the Androids and evolving and
those outside of the network create
their own purpose some of them find more
simple things to latch on to but others
as we'll see even lean towards religion
for answers father CVO for example is a
sort of Mr Miyagi type instructor who
challenges us to Du every so often
getting stronger and stronger with each
battle until we finally fight to the
death and kill him likewise another
Android on a small aircraft challenges
you to a race and like Mr Miyagi once
you win he dies although this time he
kills himself because he finally found
someone faster than him to these
machines that was their purpose not
something as Grand as changing the world
or being an advocate for World Peace
just two guys who wanted to find someone
better than them at their craft I think
this discussion speaks for itself but
it's yet again another reason why the
game is so impressive no story about
robots learning human emotions has ever
come close to reaching this level of
writing at least that I can recall
anyway it's truly some of the best
narrative I've consumed in recent memory
and wilder than that is that somehow we
still have so much more game left to
talk about as we haven't even scratched
the surface
yet as you might expect defeating Adam
and Eve amounts to nothing as the duo
leaves before we can finish the killing
blow after dealing with them command
wants to be in 9s to look into the
machines and their way of life more
through Pascal they're then directed to
go to the forest Kingdom like much of
the side content this is another example
of machines imitating humans as this
group has managed to develop a kingdom
meaning they understand the concepts of
loyalty and social status well there
isn't much to write home about regarding
the quest there are a few moments that
occur throughout it that are worth
talking about during their exploration
of the Kingdom tub almost slips up by
calling 9s nines this was a nickname he
wanted her to call him back in the first
mission but given her flat personality
she deemed it pointless slowly but
surely the game is leaning towards the
idea of 2B accepting her emotions more
while also showing that the only one
capable of doing so is 9s in addition to
this the final scene shows the two
confronting the king or what they think
is the king of the forest Kingdom as the
only machine in the room is a small
child before another yorha soldier named
A2 arrives to kill her according to
command A2 deserted yorha years ago and
is now wanted dead for her crimes she's
not going to die in this fight but her
comment swords to will Peak your
interest as when asked why she betrayed
command she replies by saying that she
didn't betray anyone but rather command
and betrayed them early on in the game
the player may also find a side quest
related to haunting down yoran members
who betrayed the group it's only until
after we kill them that NES asks what
their crime is for only to discover that
not only is it classified but according
to the resistance leader anemon their
supposed crime which was stealing from
the resistance can't be true as they
haven't had any reports of stolen goods
these two moments start to paint a
pretty Eerie picture of command not
enough to outright cut ties with them
but enough to be a bit more weary of
their motivations lastly and in a more
light-hearted tone than the previous one
is the the introduction of the greatest
character in the whole
[Music]
series huh hey where am I um what's
that hey there guys what's
up this thing's weird tby let's kill it
wait what not good idea
no
[Music]
okay what was that if this wasn't enough
to convince you that Emil is the best
character in near well his appearances
in the previous game will probably prove
my point Emil originally debuted in near
replicant and was discovered to be
blindfolded thanks to his ability to
turn anything he looks at into stone
it's eventually learned that Emil and
his sister Hua were created to be
weapons for project Asal his sister was
deemed to be the best of the two so Emil
was basically on reserve in case
anything happened to her around this
time Emil and near fight his sister so
that they can harness her magical powers
due to some plot related issue that
happened a few missions ago this forces
Emil to abandon his old body granting
him a new skeletal body instead well
thousands of years later an Emil is
still kicking sort of due to him not
aging he was still alive when the aliens
first invaded 6,000 years ago and so we
used his magical powers to make clones
of himself to help even the fight this
Emil and utata is one of those clones
none of the emils remember the original
or even remember much at all besides
anything they learned after being cloned
in fact this Emil has a whole quest line
revolving around these memories to
progress the quest you need to find
these flowers called lunar tears to jog
his memory the final objective is to
take a key he gives you after finding
all the flowers which leads to an
underground Cavern with a shack and
hundreds of lunar tears this is why I
believe despite the games being largely
separate from each other that you should
at least play near replicant before
utata meeting ail even if he's a clone
is like catching up with a close friend
the lunar tier is also a call back to
the same flower that Yona wanted to find
as according to the old folktales the
lunar tier grants those who have them
any wish they desire and yaa went out on
her own to find ones that could cure her
disease the driving force behind why
near is trying to save her the shack is
also a redesign of K's home who is
another party member that near will
encounter on his journey the whole Quest
is pretty much a call back to replicant
and this final scene hit me pretty hard
the music that plays in this area is the
same music you hear during the credits
of each ending in replicant and it's by
far one of the best tracks from that
game and hearing that one more time had
me reminiscing about the journey I went
on with the gang KY Emil Weiss and near
were an incredible party to Adventure
with they constant bickering Main
between Kane and Weiss and the many
emotional moments that happen were
Unforgettable and while the game does
start off quite slow you'd be doing
yourself a disservice by not playing the
original it may not be as mind-blowing
as AATA when it comes to its themes and
story but the emotional moments are just
as hard as they do here and being able
to sit and recount my time with that
game created a nice change of pace from
the content I'd experienced so far sadly
Emil's main role in this game is to be a
merchant but there is a secret Quest
that he has involved in by acquiring and
fully upgrading all the weapons in the
game which is a nice nod to how some of
the endings and replica needed all the
weapons to achieve you'll find a meal
sitting in the same Mall you first found
him in he commends our strength and
recognizes that he is no longer needed
which leads to him going to the desert
apparently under the sand were giant
heads of Emil his other clones and he
came here to destroy them it's another
example of the game blending the story
with its gameplay as to even get all the
weapons upgraded you have to have tons
of materials that would take hours to
find enough money to purchase these
upgrades and be an extremely high level
as getting one of the weapons requires
you to defeat Emil who was level 99 and
if the level disparity is too big you
can't even damage him this is the last
piece of content you'll ever do in the
playthrough so Amo really isn't needed
anymore upon finding him we see that he
is wounded but despite taking a few down
there are still tons more left to defeat
to defeat him you'll have to wait for
the heads to split and then attack them
individually this does mean however that
eight different heads will be attacking
at one time it's pretty difficult and a
meal hits really hard although this may
have been on account to my build not
being optimized but as long as you have
enough potions and a fast enough
reaction time you can heal yourself
before dying this boss is also pretty
similar to one we fight later in the
story so the player can easily Inuit it
how to beat him outside of all the
technical nonsense the fight is
fantastic and the ending that played in
the cavern plays here too the meals also
talk during the fight and it gets pretty
heartbreaking at times
this
[Music]
this this
desperation you know nothing
[Music]
about but even so all of this is wrong
no matter how hard or how painful they
never gave up they kept fighting because
they believed they could overcome
someday isn't that right K even if it's
pointless you still have to do it
because this is the world my friend
tried to save Amia went through a lot of
pain having to clone himself to fight an
unwinable War losing the friends he once
held dear and for his clones to lose
their memories not knowing who they are
or why they fight it's heartbreaking to
realize how much he went through and how
much he sacrificed to save the place he
called home the IM clones won't accept
this though and the self-destruct
sequence is big enough to wipe out the
whole planet assuming you stop this
though you get a brief talk with a I did
a lot of bad things to you tby but now I
get to see them
again really soon you'll be all right we
can repair you
oh
hey there you are I'm so glad I got to
see you all
again Emil before dying Emil sees his
friends again who are most likely K near
and Weiss I think would really hit me
the hardest with these final moments
Emil remembered why he fought in the
first place and who he wanted to protect
it's a clone yes but if 2B can blow up
transfer her mind to another body and
still be the same 2B so can Emil this
being seconds before going was the real
Emil the one with all his memories
intact that's why it hit me I finally
got to meet Emil again the real ail the
boy with weird magical powers the one
who helped his friends achieve their
goals and the one who was always able to
watch their backs that was the Emil I
remember and the one I met in his
fleeting moments it's easily one of the
greatest quests in the game and is a
testament to the writing of utata as
even 60 hours in on the final side quest
the game is still connecting back to its
original theme of identity and purpose
everything about near AATA is connected
like a string of webs all stuck together
forming in the shape of a game but I
think I do need to chill out with a
commentary or I'm going to start getting
a emotional so let's return to where we
left off shall we returning to the story
2B and 9s once again have another
mission to complete this time defending
a specific location from machine threats
which goes by without a hitch until a
giant machine emerges from the ground
according to Pascal this was created to
be the ultimate super weapon designed to
attack any Android it sees however it
went rampant one day and started
attacking its fellow machines so they
discarded the thing into the ocean
hoping to never see it again well a
couple hundred years later it's back and
it's pissed it takes quite a lot of
strength to defeat the this thing
including taking one of the missiles
they were supposed to protect and using
it to perform a root canal in the old
bastard by shooting it into its mouth
the resulting explosion catches all the
Ora soldiers in the blast with 2B waking
up 8 hours later and Nas's location
being unknown as he isn't anywhere near
the surrounding area following a few
leads brings tub to the copied City a
monochromatic Recreation of some unknown
City lining the streets are dozens of
dead bodies all belong to the other
yorha members but given the lengths we
went to get here it's hypothesized that
all these soldiers were dragged here
following their deaths the reason behind
and this was likely to get Tob here as
Adam arrives and needs her help Adam
wants to learn about Humanity his
original plan was to ask Tob to bring
the humans him so he can learn and
likely kill them too she refused so now
he wants to attain the essence of
humanity and to accomplish this Adam
wants to experience human-like feelings
and emotions as such he severs his
connection to the network so he can
Embrace death and just in case tub Isn't
So keen on fighting right now he also
has 9s strung up on a wall he's putting
it all on the line for this one moment a
fight to the death Do or Die well the a
very simple fight I found the
conversations with Adam to be extremely
fascinating Adam is a machine that wants
to understand humanity and so we chose
death and pain as his starting point I
find this specific Choice very
interesting because it's the only thing
that the machines can't experience at
least not by Design Androids and
machines will have some kind of network
or storage device that can revive them
when they need to so death is of no
consequence to them they can willingly
throw themselves at obstacles without
fear of death because the inconvenience
it provides is only as long as it takes
to copy the files over humans do not
have the luxury of living forever or
being being able to revive ourselves
after dying so Adam is arguably choosing
the most human feeling possible that
said Adam is quite naive in assuming
that simply dying is all that's needed
as there was a whole lot more to the
process while dying can either be quick
and painless or long and agonizing what
is missed is the mental toll this takes
on the person dying means never being
able to see your loved ones again and
not being able to finish all that you
wanted to accomplish some die of old age
with regrets others are content with
their life and are proud of what they
did others never even got the chance to
reminisce as it's cut short either due
to a deadly illness or something s like
a car accident Adam believes death to be
something like an event a thing that
happens at the end of life when I
believe it to be more than that there's
a famous quote by confucious that says
man has two lives and the second begins
when he realizes he has just one knowing
that this is the only life we have to
live is the driving force behind so much
of Humanity's actions everything we do
revolves around death either the literal
Act of taking someone's life or
something as simple as getting up in the
morning and trying to better yourself
because you only have one life and
you're not going to waste it lying
around quite literally dying for kicks
is not the way to go about it if you're
trying to learn about death and while
Adam May understand the painful feeling
of dying he'll never be able to
understand what it fully means to humans
if he throws his body at it like most
machines
do killing Adam though does mean that 9s
is safe and 2B can bring him back to the
bunker so he can get some much needed
repairs while that's happening Pascal
gets word of another Village of machines
being created near the abandoned Factory
and he wants Tob to go with him so they
could discuss a peace treaty upon
arriving though we see that they are
dressed in elegant garbs and it becomes
quite clear that the group has created
their own religion this creates another
link that these machines share with
humans because people without purpose
can often find that purpose in God if
you take a step back and analyze the
human existence it's not hard to see why
religion is a comfortable feeling for
people many don't want to believe that
this is all we have just a short 70 to
80e life if we're lucky and that's it
and then from there it's just death and
darkness some people want to believe
that they were put on this Earth for
something and usually that means living
through God's will earlier when I talked
about Jean Paul I mentioned existence
precedes essence which meant that
Humanity Finds Its Own value and does it
come pre package with any this quote is
often used as a counterargument for
religion as Essence precedes existence
mean that Humanity was born with a
purpose from the get-go which would
likely come from our creator or God
religion for some is all the reason they
need to get up in the morning and do
better and some feel obligated to serve
God for their sacrifice by relinquishing
some of their luxuries for certain
events like lent or Ramadan it's a very
natural thing to gravitate to so it's no
wonder that the machines attempted to do
the same what I find most interesting
about this Mission though is how vague
it is we show up at the 11th hour right
when the leader dies so we have no way
to discern if this was on purpose or
what the group's values were this leads
to a lot of different interpretations
and discussions on the subject which
I've always been a sucker for to me it
seems like this active self-sacrifice
was intentional as machines are able to
resurrect as long as the machine core
isn't damaged death as we've already
covered is meaningless to them but
what's the point of practicing religion
if death isn't involved while there are
things many Believers must do while
alive much of the appeal is from what
happens after death since death is
inevitable to us this leads me to
believe that the machine saw the humans
as gods since they're practicing
religion a pretty unique concept to
humanity and thought that they could
join their human Gods if they die or
they thought that dying would make them
Gods this oddly enough makes more sense
when we get further into the game as it
does sound weird given the humans are on
the moon right now but I'll talk about
that later what initially stumped me
when I first examine this is due to what
precedes after as all the members of the
church fight us along with the other
members the general consensus among the
group seems to be our leader became a
God or met our Gods through death so we
must do the same but not every m member
seems to be on board as seen by the
infighting so either some of the members
didn't read the church syllabus when
they first arrived or more likely this
was a Spur ofth the- moment decision and
not everyone is so Keen as to throw
their lives away interestingly the
leader of the group is named kirkgard
referring to the philosopher of the same
name who is well known in Many religious
circles for his teachings and his most
iconic idiom the leap of faith for us
Gamers the leap of faith is synonymous
with Assassin's Creed where the main
character jumps from a seemingly deadly
height only to land in a baale of hay
and survive the point of the leap of
Faith as an idiom is to believe in
something that is unprovable or that you
should believe in a positive outcome
when faced with something dangerous
jumping from 100 ft in the air will
likely kill you but you have to believe
that it won't just as it's impossible to
prove that God's existence is real but
you should believe it anyway with the
hope that it will come true I'm not
personally sure how much of his
philosophy relates to this specific
Mission since once again we have no clue
what their beliefs are but just as the
real philosopher preached to those about
God's Will and believing in him despite
being unprovable the machine version
likely preached the same telling a
subject that God's gift will come to
those that believe but you need to
accept that proving it through logic
something machines usually do isn't
going to be possible no matter how many
times you crunch the numbers God can't
be proven through science which is why
the two groups often butt heads but as
the leap of faith suggests you have to
believe that this outcome you'll want
will come true even if it seems
impossible this is why his followers
believe in their leader and are willing
to follow his path as they have faith in
him so some of them either throw their
metal chassis into the pits of lava
below while the others try to take those
less faithful with them this peace
discussion is starting to be become the
opposite as the only way to escape it is
to cut through the corpses and get back
to the surface upon making it back
topside we're able to leave the factory
only to run into more machines because
we apparently can't go 5 minutes in this
game without something going wrong this
time the machines have started advancing
on the resistance camp and eating anyone
they can get their hands on they also
seem to have powered up somehow as they
have this new charge attack that kind of
makes them look like they're going Super
Saiyan the leader behind this attack is
none other than Eve who is rightfully
pissed to find out that his brother was
dead even if it was his own fault Eve is
the final boss of the game and like most
the game's fights is very well done
after multiple phases and many health
potions later Eve is finally dead thanks
to NS hacking his way into his systems
temporarily weakening him allowing him
to deliver the final blow this fight
also blew off their blindfolds letting
us see their eyes for the first time but
9 s's eyes are glowing red which is a
major symptom of the logic virus
something very deadly to Androids and is
likely caused by him hacking into Eve
this then forces Tob to kill him before
completely takes over his
body
2B after killing 9s breaks down finally
showing some emotion for the first time
all game thankfully 9s is all right as
he was able to transfer his mind into
the machines nearby so all of his
memories are intact he then goes on to
explain in grave detail how all of this
is possible but quite frankly all tub
cares about is that he's okay talk about
a character Arc tu's Evolution has been
incredible to watch unfold all of her
dialogue is basic informative and
necessary tub is generally willing to
accept things as they are and not
question orders when it came to those
yorha deserters tub saw them as such
whereas NS was willing to ask questions
he wanted to make sure what he was doing
was just and after hearing the answer he
wasn't convinced tub is the perfect
Soldier she doesn't talk never shows
feelings never questions orders and is
more dedicated to the mission than
yokaro is to the bag the only one who
was able to unleash those feelings out
of her was 9s her emotionalist being
contrasted well with 9 s's emotional
well-being and his voice actor does a
great job of acting like a human as odd
as that is to say as 9s repeats things
and over exaggerates as humans do in
fact yova gets reprimanded for doing so
see Tob finally accept part of herself
was great and even emotionally impactful
pretty much everyone in the game was
open to being emotional and dealing with
their feelings except her and it was
great to see her finally accept that
part of
herself you might be asking yourself
though if that was the final boss why is
there still more time left in the video
and why did the ending feel so rushed
that's because neata has multiple
endings it has not one not two not even
five but rather 26 total endings with
each one being a letter of the alphabet
on top of a 27th being tied to the DLC
coliseums now I'm admittedly stretching
the truth a little as 21 of these
endings letters f through Z are
considered joke endings decisions that
end the game temporarily but aren't
Cannon for example eating a fish given
to you during a quest will cause dub to
die which gives you an ending going the
wrong direction out of Pascal's Village
when the Goliath attacks the city gives
you another ending and dying in the
first mission also gets you an ending
as I said joke endings the thing they
all share is a quick text box containing
a sentence or two and then a quick
scroll through the credits before it
boots you back to the main menu it
doesn't officially end the game though
as you could just load your save again
but now with a new letter added to your
checklist endings a through e on the
other hand are the important ones but
instead of having the ending changed
depending on a last second choice made
at the end or multiple choices made
across the playthrough its endings are
rather stacked next to each other acting
as continuations of the plot that's why
many people have taken a calling them
routes instead of endings as ending
implies a sense of finality which would
be false in the context of near automata
beating route a and calling the game
done is like beating a third of any
other game and then washing your hands
with it right after no one would call
that finishing the game and only playing
route a doesn't count as finishing it
either the unfortunate bit is that we do
have to do all the content again route B
is the same 10 chapters as route a but
the game isn't so vicious so as to force
you to go through the whole thing again
as it's added new content specific to
the route most notable of which is the
new playable character for this route 9s
instead of 2B the player not controls 9s
giving them a chance to experience new
parts of the game 9s also comes equipped
with a hacking ability which allows you
to open up chest that you couldn't
otherwise unlock in tb's route and their
new side quest specific to 9s as they
usually involve the use of hacking more
important than that though is the
structure of the story since this is
from the perspective of 9s that means we
get to see where he went when he was MIA
for 8 hours following that large boss
and what he was doing at the bunker when
2B and Pascal went to meet the new
religious organization outside of 9s the
player is enforced to complete the side
Quest again as all content completed as
2B won't reappear on the map anymore as
the game tracks your progress across the
routes so all the weapons items and
Equipment you had will stay too judging
from some of the comments I saw
regarding the game it seems like if
there was a specific point that the
players dropped the game it was here and
in a way I can see why it is a lot to
ask the player especially if route a
didn't win them over personally I didn't
mind doing this over again as I found it
to be a step up from replica's attempt
at a second playthrough many of
replicant ideas carried over into otata
like having back stories of the bosses
and Prov and the player with different
perspectives they didn't see but you
have to go through that whole thing
again as the same character and nothing
in the world itself changed it was
enough to Warrant a new playthrough but
I'd be lying if I didn't think it was a
SLO to get through at times near aomata
is definitely an improved version of
this which might help make it more
palatable that said since about 90% of
this route is the same there was no
reason to take our time going in order
like the previous route so I'll be
skipping ahead and hitting the major
points so before chasing the machine
that would lead to Adam's introduction
we get a brief storyboard style cut
scene depicting a volcano erupting out
it came a god which shared its emotions
with the machines all these story books
are different depending on the scene as
some talk about the machines as a
collective group while there's discussed
specific groups like The Forest Kingdom
but the connective tissue here is that
all of them provide background to some
part of the story letting us see things
from a different perspective just like
as Ralph be left to see things from 9
s's point of view most of the general
ones talk about the machines and what
they did with these new found Treasures
as they called them which were basically
the emotions they were given like love
hate and sadness all of them wanted to
cherish these new feelings and harness
their power to find purpose all except
one who harbored immense hatred who of
course was Adam his hatred is what drove
him to becoming what we see in game
there's also another one that talks
about the machines killing their parents
or the aliens and while they were free
and able to think for themselves they
were alone in the world as a result
eventually the group then attack the
singer at the amusement park but during
the fight we see brief glimpses into rep
past the boss's actual name was Simone
who discovered the feeling of beauty and
tried her best to impress a man who
didn't notice her she tried everything
and kept telling herself that as long as
she became more beautiful then she'll
eventually succeed Ed but the man never
even glanced in her Direction in an
attempt to appeal to the man she loved
she lost sight of herself and became
something else entirely she lost herself
in the pursuit of another which was her
ultimate downfall judging by the top hat
it's safe to assume that this robot is
Jean Paul which would connect to the
name of the boss as Simone is named
after the same Simone who Jean Paul had
an open relationship with see I'll told
you to be important later interestingly
when you defeat Simone that machine
eventually comes and thanks you for
killing her which leads to you being
escorted to Pascal's Village the machine
specifically says that she was broken
and during route a I had no idea what
this meant and figured that she was just
disconnected from the network or
something but thanks to the added slid
shows from this route it seems that
broken was more literal and killing her
was able to end the suffering she put on
herself another key figure in the
machine species was the forest King that
small child we saw before A2 came and
killed it well from the extra cut scene
we discovered that 256 years before the
game a larger robot wanted to start a
kingdom except none of them knew what
that was or how to do it only that
kingdoms were things that existed what
made the decision more palatable to most
machines is that they saw kingdoms as a
large house where everyone can live
together as a family which is
technically true but after about another
hundred years the forest king would pass
on leaving the rest with the question of
what to do next they eventually decided
to seal off access to the kingdom so
they could live in peace while also
transferring the memory of the king into
this small machine child it's like the
machine equivalent of choosing the next
a to rule which is usually within the
same bloodline except these are machines
so blood relation is imposs and as you
would expect the machine baby doesn't
grow up as a matter of fact that
something many of the villagers are
confused by as they seem to expect the
child to grow up this child is of course
the same one A2 stabs when we first meet
which by all accounts was quite rude
even without the added backstory the
next boss to also get a name is the
large Goliath halfway through the game
who's revealed to be gron similar to
Simone gr's name is based on another
philosopher Carl gron but the backstory
actually connects to the real person
grun once argued that humans are
material creatures who by Nature needed
a community for others in order to
survive this is rather ironic as the
boss Grom was abandoned by his machine
brothers and left alone at the bottom of
the see for hundreds of years following
this fight is when all the youra troops
are blown away and now we can see what
9s was up to in the meantime don't get
your hopes up though as it's a lot of
text and walking around in the
cyberspace hacking miname not exactly
the best way to do it but the info is at
least semi-important most of a text is
stuff we already know like how the
machines are imitating human emotions
but weirdly when the machines fail they
just do the same thing again so if one
were to establish a dictatorship would
fail they would just start it up again
the same way without ever learning which
is a nice commentary on how history
often repeats itself no matter how many
times we learn about it this miname
shoots us right to when Adam dies so we
are really light speeding our way
through the chapters now due to his
critical condition Nas is then sent into
the bunker for repairs and it's here
where we learn one of the biggest
revelations in the entire game when
accessing the Bunker's records he
discovered that many of the containers
sent to the moon are empty when they
should be full supplies and that the
Council of humanity was a directive
created by yorha when it should have
been the other way around the commander
eventually comes clean and says plainly
that humanity is extinct and it has been
4 thousands of years far before before
the aliens even arrived on Earth so
Humanity was never on the moon and the
humans never fought the aliens as they
died before they even showed up the
biggest question of course is how is
that possible well to explain we have to
go back to near replicant but that
requires us to talk about the final boss
and lots of endgame spoilers so just in
case this video has piqued your interest
in replicant and you rather play the
game for yourself then skips the time on
screen assuming you would like to
continue then strap in because the
reason for Humanity's downfall is
actually rather comedic as it's all our
fault for a brief recap Humanity was
dying from the white chlorination
syndrome brought on by Kim and angelus's
fight with the Queen Beast this led
Humanity to create project AAL an
experiment that would separate a human's
body and soul so that they could live on
while the rest figured out a cure these
yellow and black shades as the game
calls it Are the souls and the human
bodies we talked to in the game are the
bodies of those Souls the plant failed
when the replicants of the body started
gaining a Consciousness becoming more
than just the shell this resulted in the
soul or shade of that body to relapse
causing them to lose their sapiens and
mean nothing more than a Mindless
creature while the rep replicant or the
body would develop the black scroll
disease the main protagonist of the game
near is also technically the villain as
in the opening moments we see him
defending his sister Yona from the
shades before using the power of the
black book to gain magical powers this
eventually spit his body and soul like
the rest but due to his power he became
the shadow Lord the leader of the shades
the shadow Lord is the soul version of
near while the main character after this
is the body version of nearer so the
protagonist and antagonist are the body
and soul of the same person due to his
overwhelming power the shadow Lord was
able to keep the shades in check but
thanks to near killing him at the end of
the game The Shadow Lord lost his grip
on the shades causing the black scrawl
and relapsing to come back this is
actually one of the major plots within
replicant that not only are we killing
humans since the shades are The Souls of
the humans but that we're also
technically the villain although to be
fair a large part of replicant is that
villains aren't real it's just that
people are doing what they can to
survive and save the ones they love as
both the soul and body version of near
did what they did to save their sister
Yona as a result of the Shadow Lord's
death though Humanity eventually died
out over the course of the next Thousand
Years years so the bodies and souls all
perish leaving nothing behind however
the Androids were created before
Humanity died out Deva and Popa two
people all bring up later were the
game's one and only Androids as they
were created to oversee project Asal so
Androids did exist back then which is
important as eventually aliens invaded
But many of the Androids started hearing
rumors that Humanity was dead causing
them to lose morale so a few Androids
who knew the truth got together to
create yorha who then created the
Council of humanity to give off the
impression that Humanity was still on
the moon waiting for the Androids to
finish the war for them so yob was
created to be alive from the get-go
Humanity died out years ago and they
were never there for the fight against
the aliens so to recontextualize our
timeline at the beginning of the video
the humans didn't overcome the white
chlorination syndrome it killed them and
the war wasn't humans and Androids
versus aliens and machines it was Emil
in the androids as we know that Emil
cloned himself to help fend them off
humans never played a role in the war at
all as they were never even there to see
the start of it it's easily the biggest
Revelation so far and explains lots of
the weird behavior during the game such
as why we never see the faces of the
council and why their messages were so
stiff when asked why she was willing to
divulge this info so easily the
commander says that no one fights
without a reason and that they need a
God Worth Dying For relating back to the
entire theme of the game creating a
false statement that humans were alive
gave the Androids a purpose to live and
a reason to die just as humans see our
creators as Gods humans are the creators
of the Androids so they saw Humanity as
gods and it's because of this
fascination with them that the Commander
in the others who knew the truth spread
lies about humans that the Androids had
a purpose as without the idea that they
were fighting for Humanity they would
both let the machines trample over them
since it wasn't worth fighting anymore
and they would also lose their lives and
Home in the process something yorha is
trying to prevent so instead of the
machines who forcefully created their
own purpose due to their own actions
Androids are falsely given a purpose
that they don't know is already gone
something you may have noticed though or
at least thought about is yorha itself
the bunker is one of the only places in
the game with this monochromatic look
and according to Yoko Taro This was
meant to symbolize how lifeless the
place is and how it's eventually going
to cease existence the outfits worn by
the Ora soldiers ALS also a nice touch
as each member either has a mask or
blindfold on them referring to the three
wise monkeys See No Evil Hear no evil
speak no evil which in the case of AATA
means how each of the yorha troops are
being deceived and not being told the
full truth to add to this there are only
two people who know the truth or at the
very least know that yorha is corrupt
and they're also the only two
individuals without something Block in
their eyes or mouth who are the
Commander in A2 so maybe her command was
the one who betrayed you line might have
more meaning than originally thought
then finally to wrap this whole section
up the very last instance of new content
comes at the very end of the fight with
Adam where when 2B is choking out 9s we
can see two girls in red dresses
watching over them well not important
these two will appear soon so it's an
attempt by the game to foreshadow the
upcoming storm overall route B is a
solid piece of content and should
hopefully explain why I prefer to call
them routes instead of endings as these
new Revelations add more to the story by
either giving us other perspectives we
weren't familiar with or by outright
changing the entire plot it can seem
very daunting to go through the whole
game again with very little change and
that's still something I agree with but
I find that at at least from a story
perspective the struggle is worth it
route B might not provide as many
opportunities to engage in philosophical
discussions as route a but it was never
meant to as it was intended to be an
addendum to the previous route giving us
more context to our actions and
explaining things that the original
route may have left
untouched one thing you'll have noticed
about route A and B is that so far
outside of the philosophical discussions
the story has been quite basic Androids
are the good guys machines are the bad
guys Androids defeat the bad guys and
that's it roll credits it's the template
for a very generic Act movie one that
may be centered around the action and
not so much its themes which is why near
automata following suit is rather
strange that's because the game was
holding its cards until they were ready
as were now given access to routes C and
D which not only come with seven
additional chapters but it's where the
story starts to take a turn if the first
two routes were all about providing the
player a sense of normaly and comfort
then these routes are all about tearing
that fairy tale down before that happens
the game attempts to attract the players
attention by giving them a preview of
the events to come I'm getting a lot of
phantom pain flashbacks here and un
fortunately they share more similarities
than just this inclusion as like the
second half of met Gear Solid 5 routes C
and D are where things start to go south
fast it starts with tub and the rest of
yorha getting new outfits as the group
is pulling out all the stops to finish
this war once and for all the operation
goes off without a hitch until a large
scale EMP affects all the oran members
followed by a logic virus which infects
them right after this is something we
saw with 9s earlier and now we're seeing
it once again thanks to 9 s's hacking he
and 2B are able to quell the effects of
it for now but seeing as there entire
Army was just infected they need to tell
command but the connection isn't working
so in an admittedly smart decision they
blow themselves up again and then
transfer their minds to a body of theirs
in the bunker sadly the rest of the
bunker has also been infected including
the commander leaving 9s and 2B as the
only members of yorha left so it's
already been less than 30 minutes and
already yorha is gone like I said things
go south pretty quickly here yorha isn't
the only one who is nearing the end
though as tub gets attack during her
Ascent to Earth before the virus comes
back and disengages most of her system
systems she then has to crawl all the
way to the mall only to be saved by A2
but if the white and black colors didn't
give it away something is going to cease
existence soon and it's not
A2 2B
2B
2B are
you
nice
oh
no
TP
no A2 kills 2B to stop the logic virus
from spreading but from ness's
perspective 2B was murdered it's a
pretty heartbreaking scene especially
since this is the first time 2B calls 9
S9 and meant it it goes without saying
but it's yet another gut punch for the
game this time time with more emotional
weight behind it 2B is the protagonist
of the game and the one you'll likely
spend the most time with so it's
understandable that this moment hit a
lot of people hard including myself she
was just able to accept the side of
herself that she repressed and now won't
be able to see it flourish due to her
death her and n's relationship seem to
be advancing quite steadily as well one
of their talks was about going to a mall
after the war to go shopping together
and within each weapon is an item
description which uncovers more story
The more you upgrade them as someone
who's dabbled in a few item descriptions
from time to time for video this was a
nice stripped down memory lane but two
of the weapons called virtuous contract
and cruel oath are the default weapons
of 2B and 9s each one seems to be
written from their perspective and while
9 s's is about his past 2 B's is about
her wondering how long she can keep
fighting and protecting the one she
loves she cared just as much about 9s as
he did her and honestly a shopping trip
sounded rather
nice from here though the player is
given the chance of playing as either 9s
or A2 both of them have their own set of
chapters and you'll be forced to do them
anyway it just depends on what order you
want to do them in so seeing as she's
finally given more than 2 seconds of
screen time I think it's only fair we
start with A2 A2 like the others is an
Android but is an older model which
might explain why the logic virus didn't
affect her and why she seems to be one
of a kind her backstory is also quite
unique as she was deployed as one of the
first yorha models along with a few
others and were tasked with defeating
machines at a specific location along
with them was an operator who was tasked
with monitoring these soldiers so they
can use their data to make more
effective Advanced models like 2B it
seems like yorha expected all these
models to die for the sake of combat
data but A2 was able to survive thanks
to the operator saving her given that
she was a rare model and knew the nature
of the mission she was ordered to be
killed by the other yorha members so the
truth wouldn't get out so as expected
she isn't a murderer but someone who was
betrayed and slandered due to this she
has been on her own ever since and has
developed quite the rude attitude
towards pretty much everything mouthing
off at anyone and everyone that speaks
to her this also extends to the machines
including our lovely friend Pascal who
probably would have been stabbed
immediately by A2 if it wasn't for us
controlling her similar to 2B though A2
eventually starts to warm up to the
machines by interacting with them there
are also a few unique side quests
involving A2 one of which has you
building a slide for the kids at the
Village all of whom are extremely
grateful and even call her Big Sis A's
rough outer shell slowly starts to chip
away the more she interacts with the
village and she honestly comes to enjoy
their company if only this game could
have a happy ending once in a while as
Pascal's Village will be overrun by the
logic virus so A2 has to deal with the
rampant machines while Pascal gets the
children to safety not many of them can
be saved however requiring us to kill
most of the village we've spent a couple
dozen hours help Thrive not to
completely switch the tone of this
dramatic scene though but I did find it
extremely funny that the only living
survivor of the village that wasn't
taken by Pascal is this kid in his room
he's from a 9s specific Quest where the
kid keeps locking himself in his house
because he's scared of the outside world
and then vows at the end of the quest to
be the world's best shut in and since
the door can only be opened by 9s he
becomes the one surviving member of The
Village proving that you should never
leave your house and stay inside for the
rest of your life that aside both A2 and
Pascal decide to meet up with the old
factory and set up shop there but the
machine seem to have found them this
leads into a pretty difficult fight but
thankfully watching our back is Pascal
yeah the passivist machine renounced
their oath in order to protect the
children which goes to show how much
Pascal cares about them and it's that
part in particular that really stings
the
most no no how
[Music]
can all of the kids have died or more
specifically they killed themselves
Pascal taught them emotions and feelings
in order to prepare them for the real
world one of those emotions Was Fear so
the children didn't just run headlong
into danger but it didn't seem like
Pascal taught them how to cope with fear
as they figured the best way to resolve
this terrible feeling was killing
themselves Pascal in the midst of
breaking down asks A2 for help he can't
bear the thought of his memory haunting
him for life so he asks her to either
kill him or to wipe his memory the
question that's at the core of this is
whether or not something is worth giving
into or avoiding entirely in a less
deadly example this harmful memory is no
different than a breakup you don't want
to live with the memory but you have to
the best way to get over a breakup is to
understand that what happened happened
and then move on that's easier said and
done of course but it's the only way
Pascal can't find the strength to carry
on due to the severity of the ACT but to
me staying here alive is the best
outcome which is something you can
choose as a lesser known third option is
simply walking away Pascal won't be
heard from again but I find this to be
the best outcome whether or not they are
able to move past this horrific moment
is uncertain but what he choose to do as
a result should not be my choice taking
his own life or wiping his memory should
not be my own choice to make as it's not
right to take away someone's final
decision leaving means that Pascal isn't
heard from again killing him obviously
kills him and wiping his memory makes
him return to the Village adding how
calm this new place he discovered is
Pascal has no idea that this was once
his village but given what we know about
the machines it's safe to assume that
pas scale might start the village up
again since all machines tend to repeat
their past actions that is definitely
the more palatable of the two binary
options but then we can do a deeper
discussion about whether or not this is
the real Pascal and if there's something
that should have even been done in the
first place plus he ends up becoming a
merchant and selling you weapons you can
only get through him and they seem to be
assembled from the parts of the dead
children which is pretty creepy still
this is a very traumatic moment for him
and I find that not embracing that
moment reving in all of its emotions but
instead avoiding it is only going to
make it worse it's not really a great
come either way but the faster he can
recognize that what happened happened
and that nothing he could have done
would change the outcome the faster he
can move on and start a new near
automata in the second half is really
pulling on the heartstrings as most of
the characters we've come to know and
love are dying right in front of us
Pascal's Village definitely hurt the
most as they're just a small group of PE
machines that got caught in the
crossfire and at this point in the
playthrough I literally just built that
slide for them too and now all the kids
calling me big sis are dead right here
on the cold Factory floor thus signaling
the end of A2 chapter
while E2 is busy doing this 9s on the
other hand is saved and wakes up after
falling off the bridge due to the large
Tremor which spawned a massive Tower
right in the middle of the map when
accessing the Tower of voice on the
intercom tells us that we can't enter
until we access the three pillars next
to it as well as a prize being given to
the winner who makes it to the top first
this requires us to head to these large
resource units and grab the keys located
at the top the unit seem to be a massive
resource collector that the giant Tower
will use to then craft more machines
during this 9s also gets a pretty
important side quest he can tackle which
sees him Gathering momentos of an
Android's Fallen comrades that he can
mourn their loss seeing this brings 9s
to do the same and will place a stick
and a blindfold in 2 B's honor well this
could be seen as 9s getting over his
grief that unfortunately is not going to
happen and is arguably the sole
motivator behind his current manic State
as despite his pod's assessment he
refuses to get repaired and wants to
keep going far past his limits he is
completely hellbent on not only killing
the machine in his way but also killing
A2 for what he did to 2B from here on
though the player's going to be
switching off between A2 and 9s at
certain points as they they're roughly a
few feet away from each other at all
times but once all the keys are found
the tower can be open NS attempts to get
in but the hack takes too long Ling him
assistance though are the twins DEA and
POA these two like a are characters from
replicant and also have appeared quite a
bit throughout the story already but I
found it easier to summarize everything
all at once as I mentioned earlier
devila and Popa were two Androids
created to oversee project Asal but
thanks to near and Company they failed
in their mission this devila and Popa
are not the same ones from replicant
like all the Androids they're the same
mod but not the same exact ones
according to them there was a Deva and
PPA unit stationed at Key areas all
across the world but the twins from
replicant were the ones that failed this
caused the twin models to be
discontinued with the ones still alive
being implanted with a device that wiped
their memory and gave them constant
feelings of never- ending guilt
including our twins after the collapse
of the project they scoured the land for
days hoping to find residents at
different settlements but everyone
turned them away thanks to what their
other models failed to do so they're
basically being blamed for the actions
of their sisters this ultimately ends up
leading to their deaths as as when they
eventually arrived at the resistance
Camp they were given all the crummy jobs
nobody wanted but they did them anyway
since they felt like they needed to
atone and them defending 9s is another
example of them atoning and while they
did succeed it seemed like it cost the
two their lives this particular moment
once again locked me in for another ride
in the emotional roller coaster not only
did I enjoy devila and Popa in both
games it's honestly quite sad to see
that they died atoning for something
that wasn't even their fault yes they're
the same model but each model is
arguably a different person even if they
look the same so them dying here while
Valiant is actually rather depressing as
they Liv their lives thinking they
failed everyone when in reality they did
nothing wrong eventually 9s will make it
towards the top and gets surrounded by a
dozen 2B models who are trying to kill
him NS sees no issue in this though and
actually Revels in the idea of killing
her whereas 2B went from emotionalist to
emotional in route a NS has gone from
light-hearted and optimistic to Fallon
edgy nihilism it's hard not to
understand why though the kid just
learned that their gods are dead yorha
was lying to him the whole time and all
the soldiers he worked with are dead
along with the girl he clearly loved
after that what's the point honestly why
bother caring anymore he's got nothing
left to live for or to fight for it's
why I think the owners of the tower who
are the Red girls are doing this to him
on purpose as they want to break him
while also watching from the sidelines
just to see how far they could push him
yes 9s has done a complete personality
change but it was handled exceptionally
well letting it ease out over the course
of the route to make his more Sudden
Change believable all throughout this
route though the player has been
possibly finding breadcrumbs of
information and this coupled with what
9s is about to learn right now manages
to somehow once again change a
perception of the game the first was
that there was a classified plan to
destroy project yorha the plan was to
have the bunker be attacked by machines
who would blow up the bunker along with
all the evidence it has including this
archive this is supposed to ensure that
the Androids on the surface never
discover the truth about humanity and
thus continue to fight the war against
the machines the other piece of info
says that the black boxes within the
yorha Androids are made up of similar
material to that of the machine cores
meaning that the consciousness of the
Androids and machines are the same same
this is where things start to get a
little confusing and actually quite
annoying if I'm being honest as each of
these files has level SS confidentiality
stating that no one not even the
commander can know of this info but that
begs the question if the commander
doesn't know then who's higher than her
well many point to two individuals named
number nine and Zenia these two are
never mentioned in the game at all and
only briefly referenced in a stage play
and multiple voice dramas release post
launch apparently they are the original
creators behind the Council of humanity
and project yorha and these documents
explain their plans it's a nice piece of
info to have but I feel like some
references to these characters in game
would have been nice I've long since
said that important info like this
should always be put in the game and
outside material especially if the
series starts from a game and is not an
adaptation of a book and while I can
understand wanting to use different
methods to convey certain plot elements
these two characters not even being
mentioned once in game is a little
strange to me so instead of talking
about two figments of our imagination
let's instead talk about two characters
who actually exist the red girls also
known as N2 according to them they are
the ego or personality of the machine
Network basically a physical
manifestation they are the main
antagonists of the game and are the
reason for most of what goes on during
the game especially during this route
after killing off the aliens the
machines were lost and without purpose
as their only directive was to defeat
the enemy so N2 here decided that they
could keep their objective as long as
they never complete it and in the
meantime would then use the Androids to
evolve as long as the war keeps going
each group is going to get stronger and
stronger the Androids by building better
Android roids and the machines thinks of
them eating those androids well they
realized that if they killed off the
Androids and one then they wouldn't have
a purpose anymore along with them not
having any easy source of nutrients to
eat that would allow them to evolve so
they continue to perpetuate the war
likely until they can't evolve anymore
this is also an answer behind some of
the deficiencies within the network and
why some of the machines chose to leave
the network like Pascal and the forest
Kingdom as they believe that doing this
would allow them to diversify their
evolution this doesn't seem to imply
that Pascal and the Kingdom's actions
were not their own but their choice to
leave the network work seem to be
controlled by the red girls what they
did after was done without the girls
input the girls telling the forest King
and Pascal to leave though does bring
into the discussion about whether or not
any of this was truly their own it seems
like what they chose to do Post removal
was their own choice but it's kind of
like putting your essence before your
existence within the network they were
told to kill and while they're free to
do what they want out of the network
they were instructed to leave so can it
really be said that what they're doing
is their own will I personally would
like to think so since the red girls
don't seem to have a hand in their
Endeavors but that seemed to be the
point they want it to be involved by not
being involved if that makes sense it
doesn't make Pascal or the force King
any less human or interesting but it
does beg the question of whether it can
be truly called free will if this is
what the network wanted somehow more
shocking than this is info about tb's
real name to be or not to be that is the
question as 2B is not Tob but rather to
e we haven't talked about this yet but
the yorha Androids all have a letter and
number attached to their name but their
letter means a specific class 9s is a
scanner or S type robot the E is an
executioner class Androids with an yorha
who specifically killed deserters and
betrayers of the organization but 2B
purposely had her class hid because
unlike the others who would just be
assigned to kill any Android 2B was only
allowed to kill one nine s apparently
the 9s type model is very proficient at
discovering the truth about yorha and
Humanity being extinct so 2E models are
designed to work with 9s models and then
kill them when they get close to finding
out the truth surprisingly much of this
was hinted back as far as the first
mission as 9s asked why a combat unit
would be paired up with him since
scanners usually work alone this also
might explain why 2B constantly tells
him to keep his emotions in check as
opposed to everyone else since letting
him get curious would eventually lead to
his death in addition to this when
investigating the body records in the
bunker the storage of 2B is marked with
a y or yes implying that her body is in
there but that can't be possible since
she's on the surface hinting that 2 B's
real name is not 2B there was also a
brief conversation during a section with
A2 where it says normally we'd call you
blank but instead we'll call you 2B and
most notable and depressing of all is
when 2B kills 9s at the end of chapter
10 she says it always ends up like this
possibly implying that she has killed 9s
models many times before judging based
on what we know it seems like 2B doesn't
know what info 9s is actually finding as
she never mentions anything odd about
yorha or the Council of humanity which
I'd argue actually makes this worse as
it seems like she was just told one day
to kill him and yet despite not knowing
why does it anyway I guess that kind of
explains her cynical by the book
attitude better to just not question
orders and keep your head down rather
than let all that pain get to you sadly
for 2B 9s is a chatter box and
constantly tries to talk to her which I
can't imagine feels good no one shall
eventually have to kill him again
weirdly it seems like 9s might know this
the last fight at the end of the game
seems to apply that 9s knows about to be
killing him all the time and the game
seem to be hinting in this before the
big reveal when walking through the
resource units NS ends up getting hacked
and sees that it's trying to rip his
memories of 2B away from him so he has
to defeat this thing hacking his systems
only for it to be 2B it's not actually
her mind you but it just uses a neat
method of symbolism as he says these are
my memories and you can't take them away
from me something that could be applied
to both the machine he's fighting and 2B
to add to this when 9s went missing for
those eight hours and found all those
records on the machines Adam ends up
intervening and says you're thinking
about how much you want a blank 2B
aren't you initially I just thought this
was calling out every horny person
playing this game but that four-letter
word could also be kill referring to how
much 9s wants to kill to be for taking
his memories from him that is mainly
just speculation on my part though but
if true I find this reveal to be even
more compelling due to how many times
this was hinted at that last fight I
just mentioned though is about to happen
right now as eventually A2 and 9s make
it to the top and talk about the info I
just relayed to you leading to the final
Choice what are you
know you don't know anything at all
about us proposal cease combat fighting
her at this point would
be3 I order you to Halt all logical
thought and speech this order shall
remain in effect until you confirm the
death of either myself or unit
[Music]
A2 we must now make a choice the old
friend who's gone off the deep end or
the levelheaded newcomer either option
leads to an ending but does require you
to fight the other realistically I feel
that A2 is the correct Choice 9s is not
in the right State of Mind to be making
any Grand decisions so I would have
picked A2 she wants to destroy the tower
since a rocket is being aimed at the
moon and plans on destroying the human
server on the moon 9s doesn't care and
sees everything as pointless humanity is
extinct Androids aren't needed anymore
and you're hot along with all the data
was going to be destroyed as well so why
bother 9s also says that her killing 2B
is the only reason he needs to kill her
which on that note this whole route
employs quite literally my least
favorite Trope in any medium ever and
that's the lack of communication A2 goes
the whole route without ever telling 9s
why she killed 2B which could have saved
a lot of headaches in the future to be
fair to the game they only meet three
times and the first two have 9s falling
which feels a bit forced but at least
they considered the idea A2 does have
time to throw out one sentence though
before he falls and she decides to tell
him that 2B wanted him to be a good
person which yeah that's a fair thing to
say but from his perspective it's more
like hey remember the girl I killed the
one you loved well I have her last words
for you it's no wonder 9s attacks her
right after I can respect her not
mentioning it by the next time they meet
up though as by then 9s would have been
too far gone so nothing would have
gotten through to him I don't know if A2
lost her social skills having been alone
for years but I just think a quick
4-second conversation to clear things up
would have been nice but if that
happened we obviously wouldn't have had
this dramatic moment which is admittedly
pretty cool if a bit forced if you
choose A2 she defeats 9s and hacks into
his mind in an attempt to repair his
logic circuits by removing the virus the
Pod then takes 9s away while the tower
crumbles taking A2 with it the only cut
scene that follows is 9 s's sword and
bag stuck in a rock not exactly helpful
but this seems rather fitting as A2 is
continuing to be's Legacy when she was
killed A2 took her sword which contained
her memories in it so it's clear that
she cared about 2B and wanted to do
right by her which is why she didn't
want to kill 9s and instead sacrificed
herself realistically she's been a dead
man walking since the first mission she
embarked on she's lived far past her
expiration date and is almost in a
completely new world as all of her yorha
friends were the older models ones that
died out years ago so this is her
finally accepting her death and doing
right by 2B if you choose the other
ending both of them end up killing each
other following this fight was supposed
to be a rocket that would be launched at
the Moon by the red girls while the
humans aren't on it anymore the human
genome is so destroying that would truly
mean the end of human life but instead
they opted to turn the rocket into an
arc the girls saw people like our
Androids and Adam and Eve as as Unique
Individuals who live different lives
they saw them and started to question
the meaning of existence and then came
to a different conclusion instead of
shooting a rocket at the Moon they were
going to turn the artillery into an arc
filled with the minds of the machines
hoping that one day it would land on
some distant planet and bring about New
Life interestingly nanus is able to see
inside the ark right before dying and
notices that Adam and Eve are there yet
despite seeing them Harper is no anger
or resentment towards them n starts the
question whether or not he hates the
machines now or if he even hated them to
begin with at then ends up asking 9s if
he wants to come with possibly implying
that 9s will also be on the ark given
that the cores of the Androids are based
on the ones from the machines that could
mean that he'd be able to join them in
fact all the Androids could join them by
that logic including our recently
deceased Trio and while that is a rather
Sound Idea the game will not allow us to
see that outcome mainly due to the game
having its own plan for
us I mentioned earlier how there were
five important endings in near automata
and it's about time we talked about the
last one once you complete both endings
the pods come back and talk about the
deletion of the Android's data as laid
out in the plan we talked about earlier
all your high unit data must be deleted
meaning everything will be wiped and 2B
9s and A2 will be officially gone not
one record of them will even exist
however one of the pods can't accept
this outcome and asks the player if they
want to salvage the remaining data even
though completing this task would be
impossible if you accept you were taken
into another hacking style miname where
you have to defeat all the devs
contained in the credits the first 10
minutes or so is honestly not too bad
but it becomes extremely C when Square
Enix appears on screen dying however
will result in you getting a message
yeah from another player named Vortex
3164 who said I did my best one thing is
for certain rely on your own strength so
I continued on and died again and more
messages popped up from all over the
world all of these messages are meant to
encourage you to keep going even though
this miname starts to become impossible
because alone it is after enough deaths
the game starts summoning other Sprites
letting you control up to seven turrets
at once each of these messages are from
real people and these turrets are other
people's data helping you achieve the
final ending Senor utata ends in a very
Bleak way with everyone we love dying in
front of us this ending rejects that if
you choose to continue this ending you
reject the fact that the story is over
and are willing to do whatever is
possible to continue it the devs want
ending C inde DED to be the finale but
the players want more but the only way
to do that is to take the fight to the
devs themselves shooting the team's
names is us taking the fight to their
product and due to the message system it
gives off the idea that everyone all the
players of near alamata are coming
together to fight the devs and arguably
the most important battle in history as
the result of this war will determine
the lives of the characters we hold dear
it is without question one of the best
endings I've ever seen the game
constantly hounds you with the same
message asking if you want to quit
hoping that you will give up but those
messages from other players players who
have not only gotten as far as you but
have beaten the thing that is currently
besting you those messages are meant to
give you hope continually giving you a
reason to keep going to push forward to
not not stop until you finally beaten
the impossible challenge all of this is
done without so much as a hint that this
ending is actually possible you have to
die close to six or seven times before
the other turrets start to appear and by
then some people may have already
clocked out realizing it's too tough for
them it's a beautifully told and
well-conveyed ending as it brings the
community together one final time the
song playing during this ending is also
called The Way of the World and
according to yotaro the choir in the
background is actually members of the
dev team almost like they're cheering us
on wanting us to defeat them it is a
perfect encapsulation of everything
we've talked about for the past hour all
the characters in this game wandered
around the world looking for a purpose
and some of them either achieved that or
died in the process our purpose now is
to give that time back to them beating
this ending seiz both pods discussing
how they seem to have gathered all the
past memories and parts from the group
which makes one of them question if it's
just going to lead to the same outcome
again the other pod doesn't know though
it could lead to the same result as last
time with all of them dead but it could
lead to something different ending it
with a future is not something given to
you it's something you must take for
yourself we are not given a predestined
outcome we create that outcome the final
part of the game sees the pods talking
directly to the player asking if you
enjoyed playing while also asking if you
want to help someone in need what this
means that we can become one of the
turrets in another game but to do this
we have to make the biggest sacrifice a
player can possibly make within a game
they must delete their entire save file
everything you have done since starting
the playthrough will be wiped gone from
existence and by the time you're
watching this video my save file will
indeed be wiped cuz it's the right thing
to do it would be selfish of me to have
gotten this much help only to not pay it
forward along with this is a message you
can send to the players that die
encouraging them to keep going I thought
long and hard about this and after about
20 minutes I landed on the world is Rife
with hardship so believe in yourself I
wrote this because I wanted it to apply
not just to the miname but to life
itself the world is going to throw some
curve balls at you from time to time but
none of that matters as long as you get
up nothing good in life ever comes easy
that's a saying I've kept with me for
years whether it is in my early years of
you back in 2016 not knowing if the
channel would ever take off or more
recently when I've been hitting the gym
I've always told myself this whenever I
start to doubt myself and this same
saying can be applied here the world can
be hard and achieving your goals can be
equally as hard but as long as you
believe in yourself believe that you can
accomplish the thing you want you will
succeed that's the kind of message I
wanted to leave for someone hoping that
it will give that person enough hope to
give the ending one more try near
automata is a game with a tremendous
amount of visual storytelling and is
easily one of the best games I've played
in recent memory
very few games have attempted the things
near aomata does with its plot and
themes and even fewer have actually made
it work it's an absolutely beautiful
game filled with a gripping emotional
moments intense combat and flusher
background low as far as the eye can see
it's a game I could recommend with ease
as there is very little if anything
actually bad about it that is why I
wrote the message and deleted my file I
want others to also experience this game
for the first time and if I can help
even just one person then I know I did
the right thing it's a pretty tough
ending but that's why I'm hoping mine
and everyone else's messages can help
the those new to the game beat it
because there's greatness on the other
side of that Hill you need to struggle a
bit to get there thanks for
watching thank you all for watching
today and I hope you enjoyed playing
your automata was definitely a great way
to start off the new year don't you
think currently I'm thinking about doing
returnal next although there might be
one of my strictly informative story
explain videos out before then but at
least when it comes to analysis and
opinionated content I'm leading towards
returnal as of right now if for whatever
reason something comes up and I have to
Pivot to something else then I'll let
you know and if you turn on
notifications then you'll be updated via
the community tab like I always do
regardless like the video If you enjoyed
And subscribe if you're new thank you to
my returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye